moi c'est zoé j'ai 21 ans j'ai arrêté
les études cherche un appart chercher là
bas vous présence d'eau et je vous ai
parlé en 6,7 colloque c'était comme une
famille et qui dit famille dit au bruit
c'est quoi c'est parce que je baise bas
c'est quoi ton délire un titre est-ce
que je base ma non tu bosse bien et bien
sûr tu ce poste au lycée arthur ça
faisait cinq ans qu'il travaillait dans
une banque
moi je serais vous je voudrais pas un
petit chien jamais pour john pleine nuit
il réussissait à y trouver son compte
spacieuse pour caroline quant à elle son
emploi du moment ne lui permettait pas
vraiment de mettre ses compétences à
profit de prison une capacité de
concentration proche du château marmont
aujourd'hui je me bouge je trouve un taf
raymond cacolac c'est à ce moment là que
j'ai compris des jeunes c'est pas juste
une catégorie d'âge fait une place
sociale
on nous devons tous font rien nous
donner en échange donc ils mentent pour
récurer des chiottes pour faire des
fichiers excel jusqu'à pas d'heure comme
éric liaud non faut qu'on entre en gare
on va créer une liste des choses qu'on
acceptera plus au monde short exactement
notre objectif attaquer le système de
l'intérieur pour la première fois j'ai
compris qu'elle force nous pouvions être
tout ce qui nous manque c'est la
sensation son nous attend si on veut
changer les choses il faut penser plus
grand mais il faut surtout penser
ensemble
un seul titre dans l'actualité de les
jeunes ont disparu c'est pas possible ça
ne pas s'arrêter à l'hymne la tanière
bordel